special almost Valentine's Day edition
speaking of Valentine's Day guys it's
right around the corner and you know
what you don't have to panic you can get
your heart on don't panic and show some
love know by matching the undies we have
matching for Valentine's Day
me and these always is in the best they
always send us matching me a nice but
these are the most important matching
manatees because they are the
Valentine's Day edition they have a
whole collection right now you get free
shipping in 20% off your first order
when you go to meet undies comm slash
Jenna Julian check it out they are
sexual the other sponsor this week is
the skin because there's so much
confusing stuff going on in the world
too many news stories too much to catch
up on that's where the skin comes in
they help you stay in the know on
important topics like Beyonce being
pregnant with twins twins all sorts of
things like that that you don't want to
have to dig for the skim does it for you
and it pops up in your email every
morning very helpful right now go to the
skin comm that's the skin with two N's
sorry two M's the SK IMM Tom /j to
Julian and to your email clips click
Subscribe and then then you're done
that's it
that's it that's all we want you to do
please do that and that's it you can
also be entered to win a $250 Visa gift
card thank you to our sponsors thank you
sponsors honestly though like I guess I
don't think about it often cuz me undies
is so great does but like well one other
place can you buy matching his and hers
underwear I wear this pair on right now
do you really the bun shop this is now a
peep show
yeah I think that's the one I have them
no that's actually a really good point
yeah you are wearing this one I can
confirm it as she's wearing this I've
actually never thought about that I mean
it's like you want a Victoria's Secret
and find men's briefs to match whatever
you're buying okay that would be [ __ ]
lit but Tracy's is already doing it yeah
that's true this mean this it's it's man
I don't even realize like I looked in my
drawer the other day all I have is me I
just realized to say anything about me
the other day yeah about me me and all
right I have a quick question for it
quick random trivia question I have to
answer on the spot what is it saying in
cupcakes Twitter bio Marilyn Monroe
what is the dial is it I'm gonna suck
two hundred twenty seventeen dicks in
2017 that's a random trivia quiz we're
adding that to the podcast from now on
we're adding pop quizzes
pop quiz questions not whole pop up
video Julian do I remember what pop-up
video maybe I do so on vh1 needs to play
at that at that point like older music
videos with maybe a couple of years old
and like videos that everybody loved but
they would have these little pop-up
speech bubbles that would tell you facts
about they popped up in a similar
fashion noise in similar fashion how on
blind date those things would pop up
about what they're thinking
Boop yeah alright keep secret here this
is what the blind date reference right
I'm not that young ooh speaking of blind
date remote that yellow Julian's wearing
a Von Dutch hat right now which I loved
I was in college or like late high
school early college when Von Dutch was
like a thing and Julian just started
watching this simple life for the first
time ever great show you guys take your
time he's like I love all their Von
Dutch stuff so he ordered himself okay
hey Von Dutch gang which if I remember
correctly bondage was expensive yes
can we frame this in a way of like I
discovered Vaughn - never like like I
work I know an okay like 20 bucks now
right yeah guys major Keeler wait 10
years
wait all completely out of style no one
wants it and then you get it for cheap
like how cheap can you buy FUBU at this
point oh okay be careful there on the
level of supreme still I mean there in
just ten years for supreme yeah exactly
you guys want some supreme hoodies just
wait Easy's wait 10 years I mean do you
remember how ridiculous those kobe moon
shoes were yeah those were the easy
everyone wanted those in paying
ridiculous prices and now look at them
where they yet I don't know but I feel
like an exception to that especially in
the Seekers like Jordans are always
expensive well Jordan is always
expensive and they probably will always
be he expects the Jordan Brand has done
a really good job of kind of
transcending that the [ __ ] trends
they kind of needs our timeless or
Jordans they've you know that they're
classics I don't know how else to say it
and sometimes classic kind of groups it
into like a oh they're old-school but
classic in a sense that like even young
kids want to wear him said how much
money do you think Michael Jordan has
sneakers on him from sneakers along
$32,000 on him charlie I mean he's built
the crazy Empire I don't know billions
of dollars probably yeah past a shoe
Empire it's like it was it's been the
most dominant brand and shoes sneakers
sneakers
I mean sneakers sorry not fashion like
you know women's stuff but I don't know
I'm not the guy to ask I'm just
speculating but Julian I like your Von
Dutch hat thank you I think it's funny
okay I was I was sort of going for funny
but I'll take it
yeah I don't care it's comfortable as
[ __ ] I got it she had to sign for it by
the way I did okay I was at the house
and you know whatever the mailman needs
me to sign for something it's a little
stressful when I'm here alone because
the dogs are like going crazy at the
door when Julian's here they're not as
bad at the door but like if he's not
here they're so [ __ ] like out of
control because they're protecting me
which I appreciate it's like five
minutes for me to wrangle them into the
office so that I can
the door and I signed for this light
feeling package I'm like what is this
and mind you Julian gets packages all
the time because he's a true millennial
and literally never shops in person and
orders like everything I name is on
Prime which makes a lot of sense but
like I don't do that as much as you do
but Julian gets a package to the house
all the time so I'm like what the [ __ ]
is this [ __ ] I have to sign for right
now I'll go Julian there's a package for
you in the stairs he opens it and it's a
[ __ ] Von Dutch hat I had to sign for
a Von Dutch hat Julian I'm tipping your
cap I used to have a pair of jeans that
said Von Dutch across the back with a
real $98 so they were the most expensive
thing I owned
we had fake Von Dutch hats because my
mom was like you guys are [ __ ] idiots
and you're not gonna pay money like 70
bucks for a hat sorry you can have
fifteen dollars and find one of the gas
station and so we did we had fake Von
Dutch hats and they were the best thing
I did you know you remember the ones
that said like Von [ __ ] and cheese yeah
those are a little too edgy for me for
me no I'm not ordering a Von [ __ ] hat
because I'm gonna have to sign for it so
fine for a von [ __ ] at not worth what
would have been worse though is if your
mom was here watching the dogs and she
had to sign for the Von Dutch come on
[ __ ] hat she would have appreciated the
bond oh my god so we wanted to do a
Dreamcast so today is the Dreamcast
asking for forever it clouds good one
thank you I was good you guys been
asking for this for a really long time
and we've been wanting to do it over
time but we are finally doing it we have
we each have a dream a pretty good dream
that we wrote down very close to one we
have a dream
and we have um revisited since no so I
haven't really revisited in my own sense
although I mine's more predictable and I
kind of sort of remember it hers is a
lot more in depth but for the first half
we wanted to kind of get into some
common dreams and what they mean just to
give a little subtext to let me get into
the dreams yeah mine mine's not any of
these when I wrote mine I like you know
how well you tell me if you've ever had
one of these dreams where you wake up
and you're like oh my god it's like
life-changing like you think it's
[ __ ] profound in your dream it could
just be like you digging in a garden
you're the jewel feeling oh my god I
know how the universe works or something
like that yeah so this was one of those
dreams and this was before we had the
idea of doing a dream cast I woke up
with this burning sensation of like I
have to write down everything that I
remember so I like sort of lucidly wrote
it like I'm half sleep half awake and
I'm falling asleep as I'm writing it but
I'm just really trying my best to get it
all in there and then after I finished
writing it it's long I fell right back
asleep and I promised myself I'm never
look at it Dreamcast until we did
something like this then I think it's
gonna be dope scared to read it you're
just gonna unleash the secret of the
universe right now no meaning of life no
it's called YouTube I think because I
literally just pulled it up and yeah
it's called I hope there's some T of T
teeth falling out it's really
unnecessary are often viewed by experts
as a symbol of confidence so teeth sorry
teeth are V teeth just by themselves are
viewed as somewhat confident so when
they're falling out in dreams that can
means that something has happened to a
person in their life to lose confidence
I know I've never really had the teeth
loss dream but this was apparently one
of the most time I have I had a dream
one time that my boobs were made out of
silly putty and every time I squeeze
them my fingerprints would be in them
ooh that sounds fun
my bag of sand it was um
so teeth falling out can also represent
a bad omen in a relationship that you
were in a bad way I always thought that
teeth falling out was like good luck no
like in dreams or in jail yeah no in
dreams
somebody told me that or I read that
somewhere the last thing I found on
teeth falling out is it's linked to
sexual wish fulfillment hmm so if your
teeth are falling on your dreams
basically it's kind of like waking up to
the fact that like you should pay
attention to this sexual desire that you
have that you're not fulfilling anyway
that doesn't really apply to me falling
I feel like a lot of people have had
falling dreams yeah I know I've
definitely had foreigners so falling
dreams can mean a whole array of things
at first what I found is it's a red flag
from your subconscious basically it's
common in people who are having major
life problems major work problems or
social problems or in their relationship
they're having problems a falling
sensation King can be attributed to
those problems also it can be attributed
to people with depression which I
completely understand anxiety and excess
of caffeine and a physical discomfort
while you're sleeping can also
contribute to a fallen yet and at first
when I was researching I was like I've
had a lot of falling dreams and I
remember all of them very distinctly and
I'm I'm not having a major life problem
I don't think I imagine most of my
falling dreams are just purely
attributed to anxiety and or kenka my
caffeine so much is good yeah I've been
having a lot of discomfort while I sleep
but that's just been because of my
shoulder right and I think that's that
would be why I haven't I've been
comfortable as [ __ ] I know I miss I miss
being able to sleep on my left side I
can't see well and I'm sure our accident
yeah showing up to work or school needed
I've never had one of these you haven't
never have one is terrible
I've showed up to a baseball game naked
in real life though the other day I
walked downstairs without any pants off
it was like a feeling of forgetting
well you know when you're like doing
something and I was like I had my head
in like 12 different places like trying
to get ready and then I just like made
it halfway down the stairs and I like
looked to my legs I was like oh for
[ __ ] sake there's a bunch of windows
everywhere I know we do all right going
to school or work naked indicates a
feeling of vulnerability or anxiety
common for people who have recently
started a new job or gone to a new
school or potentially had a promotion so
they're there's more responsibility on
them in this new position there to get
they're more in the public eye whether
it's just within a company or a group of
people or actually within the public eye
so that's that test taking in your
dreams
I've never had thought oh my god that
sounds awful you know ya have an ear
it's a reminder for a person to stay
alert for adults it means that they're
finding a link between their work and
what school was like and it can also
just be an indication of a lot of
pressure in your life man what a waste
of fun dream time mm-hmm
well you know what when I used to work
like it day camps and it was a camp
counselor in South Bay I used to have so
many dreams that I was at work or like
late for work or that I was already
working you know yeah like that would
wake up and I was like oh my god I've
been at 1 or 3 hours yeah yeah but I
always figured in softball to are like
in school I would have dreams that I'm
already in class or like I gotta make it
to class can we talk about that for a
second because I feel like that happens
when you're stressed about your job like
whatever your current job is when like
you not even your dreams are safe from
how stressed out you are so you work so
this brings me back to my bartending
days yeah you'd have dreams of you
bright - I had the worst bartending
nightmares yeah like that I was I was
asleep behind the bar and it would
happen because the thing about
bartending as you know but a lot of
bartending gigs you get off at like 3:00
or 4:00 in the morning and then you go
right to sleep and so I didn't well I
did unwind you're like wow like when I
would go go - yeah we need like an hour
to go home and my
absolutely agree with that what you need
to learn down but sometimes like so some
shifts I would I would bartend the
Saturday or Friday night and then the
next morning I had a radio shift so I
couldn't really hang out so I would
normally go to sleep within an hour so
after getting off work and it was always
that just like immediate nightmare of
like you're still at work people are
waiting on you to serve them drinks
nobody's gonna tip you you're gonna get
fired yeah what are you doing sleeping
behind the bar where have you been and
it wasn't like it was probably the most
powerful recurring nightmare I've ever
had in my life so if any of you guys are
bartenders I'm sure you know what I'm
talking about
but what's weird is I then would go to
my radio job and my radio job consisted
of board opping which was basically
being responsible for my entire radio
station staying on the air and if you
think about that that's a lot of
pressure and so I had similar dreams to
the bartending ones for that job I would
be like oh I'm at the board op we've got
we've been off the air there's dead air
for like 10 minutes I'm gonna get fired
I'm gonna get like in so much trouble
and it was just a dream and it happened
over and over and over again those were
the worst dreams I've ever had I know I
had them less about bartending and more
about when I was a camp counselor
well because it's such a social
environment well yeah and also like when
when I was a camp counselor there's like
always the pressure like I always had a
really large group I always had at least
10 kids yeah and like you know you like
you love them like they're your kids you
know by the end of the summer like you
know them so well like their parents
asked you to come babysit on the
weekends you guys grow such as close
bond or you know them for years and I
feel like you have such a like a
motherly responsibility that they wake
me up in the middle of the night you
know who's like thinking of them yeah
it's a powerful it's a powerful feeling
you know yeah but then when I stopped
then I didn't have them anymore I know
everything is bartending stuff and for
topics that I haven't had that side of
that surgery right yeah and those were
wild yeah they're really said I remember
like a nice stressful night of sleep
well cuz I remember I would like wake up
some days and I'd sit up and I'd be like
I can see that person waiting for a
drink and you're like we know that's a
lamp no I'm asleep yeah yeah that's so
real
okay dying
have you died in training before I
haven't died but I mean I've had a lot
of things where I think I die and then
wake up I've gotten really close to
dying you know I wake up dying in a
dream reveals the wish to end or
terminate some thing in your life not
your life totally so whether a job
career path or even past experiences or
decisions are sort of dogging you dying
in a dream is like you trying to get rid
of that you're trying to kill it off of
your life it can also be an encouraging
sign for someone to embark on something
new ty for like a year or so I had
recurring nightmares of drowning in
different ways over and over and over
again it was really tight yeah just
kidding it wasn't I [ __ ] hated it I
was brutal right yeah
meeting a celebrity so often times one
of those the other night yes I Barton
was on a plane across the road from me
and then our plane went down but we
didn't die and then he confronted me in
the airport and said why you keep
giggling at me when I when you when I
look at you and I was like oh it's just
cuz I have a big crush on you
I don't know car accident in front of
Steve girl's house so as random as it
might seem research indicates that the
actual celebrity is relevant to the
person dreaming about them so even if
you just you know it's true in both
cases yes exactly so you think it's
random first but really there's no there
are normally ties that celebrity has to
your life or your thought process or
whatever celebrities are a symbol of
personal need for recognition so this
may also be why your celebrity is in the
dream so if you feel like you wish that
you were recognized more in your life or
whatever or maybe you're like obsessed
with the show and you just want them to
notice you yeah I think that's it it's
like notice me senpai I think it's just
like being obsessed with someone they
show up in your dreams yeah I'm so
embarrassing being chased
despite the scary feel of this dream it
can be considered by some as a positive
sign it's often encourages the dreamer
to finally face a problem or a decision
in their life that they've been putting
off that's been hanging over the head
and they know that you should face so
sometimes the stream is meant to like
give him that little push deal with it
you know I don't have many chasing
dreams don't leach the only chasing
dreams I have and I can remember I'm
more fixated on the fact that I can't
run fast but I'm not really ever being
chased it's more sports so you're like
you're playing baseball and you just hit
like a bomb out to center field and you
like can't make it to friends you can Oh
brutal you can't and it's happened a lot
for me when I was training to like play
in college and go to showcases yeah you
would have your 40 or 60 yard dash time
you would have all these things time I
would have dreams that like I was so
ready to kill it and then as soon as
they blew the whistle I was like I
couldn't move and hated that sucks
hated that partner is cheating most
experts agree that this dream shouldn't
be taken as clairvoyance the cheating
dream can happen when a partner is
spending lots of his or her time on
something or someone that isn't you so
whether it's a hobby friends work
whatever if it's something that's not
that person they can have that dream
because the attention that their partner
is being is giving is not on them but it
can also mean you don't have trust in
your partner those are the two thing I
don't think I've ever had one of those I
have of me yeah I've told you about that
what was it I don't even remember I just
know I've had it I honestly don't
remember I think I woke up and I was
I was like it's so sad I'm sad and you
like give me a hug you're like what's
wrong announcing you kissed someone it's
like yeah I remember being so stupid and
random and then I told you about it I
was like okay I think a lot of these
things can also just be very random all
right so - anyway scooting on showing up
late to something definitely had this
yeah lots of us indicates a person is
overwhelmed and potentially doing too
much doing the most fam doing the mouth
it can also be an indication of warning
not to make promises that you can't keep
mm-hmm which is true I have liked it I'm
almost allergic to being late I hate
being late I don't know so I think I've
had these dreams because of that yeah
flying like actually flying through the
air not falling I feel like I've had a
couple of those not too many not as many
as I'd like how did it feel like you
jumped off a ledge and you just didn't
fall you're just no well I had one the
other night but I was in an airplane
I have airplanes oh yeah you know I need
planets I don't like fun
my flying encourages a person to let go
of certain issues and allow things in
their life to fall naturally into place
so basically we just chill the [ __ ] out
flying is a sign that there is it's sort
of an out of control situation you you
you have no control over time just let
it go my life yeah being preggers this
dream can also be yours Julianne
preggers dawn preggers they can be
viewed as a need to start a creative
project or potentially become a parent
it also says that this dream is common
in someone who's recently entertained
the idea of actually being pregnant then
they'll have a dream in church do you
have dreams that you're pregnant
only on Wednesdays
do you know not that I know of
weird if I had to do I was pregnant
right that's what I'm saying is this
like gender specific or do men have
dreams that they're pregnant - I've
never had that dream but I'm sure men
have had that dream that are not me is
no all right last one driving an
out-of-control vehicle very
straightforward you don't have enough
control in your life or the path that
you're on and you can be developing a
bad habit that may not be big at the
time but it could really bite you in the
ass down the line hmm I don't have any
of those like driving out of control no
I can't recall too many dreams that I
have in a car it's hard I drowned in a
car one time during that year when I
couldn't stop dreaming about drowning I
was in a tunnel like going through a
tunnel underground in a car and all of a
sudden the whole thing caved in and
everybody in the tunnel drowned oh my
god yeah I had a ton of those dreams
imagine if a tunnel was filled with
water it goes underground then yeah but
imagine if it leaked and then suddenly
the tunnel that's what happened
yeah like IRL it's happened before where
when I don't know but it happens that's
weird
because I read the skim and I didn't
read anything about it oh my god Julian
I hate you you and you segues because
there's a lot of key things happening on
the world and sometimes we're not that
great but you still need to know about
them and it can be very difficult to
have to skim through news sites and
subscriptions and nonsense on the
Internet what the skim does is they get
it all ready for you they have it nice
and tidy and packed up real good for
your eyes to just feast on and then be
smarter instantly they serve up the news
very fast and with style and no BS it's
delivered to my email inbox every single
morning and it's free guys
you have a job where you can't sit and
maybe watch a video or something you can
get the skin it's read it quietly at
your desk it's all that what you know
without any of the fluff and you know
what I could just end this pitch by
saying that Oprah uses the skin almost
like legally bound to go download it
right now you can get onto the skin comm
/ annejulien that's the skin with two
M's comm / annejulien enter your email
click Subscribe that's simple and then
you were subscribed you will be in the
know every single morning the skin makes
it easier to know what's up so sign up
right now and it's free and when you
sign up using our URL the skin two M's
calm / annejulien you are entered for a
chance to win a $250 Visa gift card
which you can spend solely on
fresh-squeezed orange juice like I would
thank you to this Kim also this week me
on these Valentine's Day is next week
guys February 14th but you don't have to
pin it because me and ease has you
covered
get y'all matching me undies guys get
your heart on right now listen me on
these matching undies they we showed you
we did a whole fashion show at the
beginning of the podcast so if you want
to see our butts wearing underwear my
butt wearing underwear just rely on the
podcast or you can go onto the MIDI site
and all their social media they have
plenty of butts in underwear and they're
unbelievably soft for made of modal
fabric that's three times softer than
cotton and with this special limited
edition Valentine's print it means you
and your Valentine can match on this
special day and have fun if you and your
me Andes aren't a perfect match then
they'll give you your money back and let
you keep the first pair but it's not
gonna happen because you're gonna love
them right now head to me and knees
knock on flesh and Julian for 20% off
your first order that's me undies M II
undies comm stops Jenna Julian 20% off
your first order and free shipping get
it right now see you have it for the
love Day coming up last a long time I
don't think I've thrown out a pair yet I
had to die definitely thrown out
underwear before that ripped on me you
have to throw underwear a bunch of no I
thought you always never
never so you've had the same underwear
since when you were a kid no because
they're not me no you've seen like my
underwear rips way too fast and then I
got me anything it doesn't have his
underwear it was a mess man all right
stop doing that alright so now we're
gonna go through your own juice me too
I'm like genuinely curious but like I
have to read this it's my only choice
you don't get to read it to yourself
first you have to read out I'm gonna
read it out loud
so the date on this is - oh my god July
11th 2016 at 7:50 a.m.
holy [ __ ] okay hit us with this hit us I
don't know if I'm ready you miserable
okay just remember if you don't like
anything you say we won't bleep any of
it out okay I literally just wrote
YouTube and some of this might be broken
in English I don't remember what I was
writing of course okay and this could be
the stupidest dream ever I don't know no
more no more disclaimers just kidding
alright so the first paragraph says
always murmurs about what happens to
people that disappear from online that
they get like reset there's this room
where we are being somehow controlled I
was staying at this official VidCon in
it was weird and dank and gross and I
was at VidCon for some reason everyone
that worked there who were all very
bizarre kept sort of screwing with me we
had a quote event the first day which
mostly consisted of like a gift suite
that was my thing to do that day and
like walk around the convention like we
did this past year no one wanted to say
hi to me Gaby literally said gab each
other
Gaby literally wow you look dot dot and
shook her head and scoff text message
and it was Gaby
I did look like I rolled out of bed I
had regular leggings t-shirt beanie on I
thought it looked alright but she wasn't
entirely wrong I just felt like she only
looked up from her phone to Scott to me
I was pretty upset okay I walked around
the event and no one wanted me there
everyone had already had it I felt so
unwelcome like I should just leave
they literally shut one of the booths so
that I wouldn't be there and go back to
my room okay I went back to my room and
there after barely being there I asked
the front desk why no one wanted me
there and what I was doing there and she
said I was rude and demanding and no one
wanted to be my mom was there my stepmom
was there car was there Gabby Rome and
Julian were all there for some reason
just alone
you knew him in the past life yeah me
and him are like on another spiritual
level okay they were doing whatever they
wanted to me and no one with me would
really listen to me I don't exactly
remember what they kept doing I just
remember being beyond my breaking point
like it was so outrageous I couldn't
handle it anymore at one point I was
literally screaming and not at a single
person would hear me as I tried to
explain why this was so wrong we were at
some loud gathering in this ends really
British homely sort of looking Lobby we
didn't even go out Friday night I
debated not even going to my meet and
greet the next day I debated just
getting a new hotel and not saying it
this one because I hated it so much the
floor was literally rotting out in
places and I kept getting lost and
everyone kept making fun of me for it
they were calling me a diva and princess
which irritated me to no end there were
so many rooms and so many people in this
Inn I was so confused how it was working
and what its layout was I asked someone
at the end why they didn't like me one
in years past they always had he cackled
dat me and said I have three videos he
shows me the first one from like 2012 my
hair was short I looked on
unrecognizably young and the end members
made workers make workers were yelling
drunk at vidcon party around me I don't
know what that sentence mean they were
all much taller than me grabbing me by
my waist hugging me in yelling and like
kissing and licking my face at the
camera I was waiting for my response
nervous because I didn't recall this
particular incident when I saw that I
did exactly what I always did I was
polite and smiled and acted embarrassed
but nicely tried to wiggle away
they showed me two other videos exactly
like that I interrupted them and said
why is that a reason to not like me
don't you see what I'm doing I'm being
nice to you and you're doing things to
my body like I'm a piece of meat at one
point I said out loud I feel like I have
no say about what other people get to do
to my body and I look over at a worker
of the end a young girl and she starts
to tear up for some reason now I've
really had it this part where I'm
screaming screaming at the top of my
lungs in this Lobby that I don't
understand why everyone's being so rude
and cold to me how this makes sense I
can't handle the madness of I feel like
I'm taking crazy pills I have some sort
of confrontation with a group of
employee women who are telling me I
deserve it and to [ __ ] off stuff like
that so I really tell them off at one
point I was really mad at the stuff that
was coming out of my mouth it was like
unlike anything I've ever said but just
really [ __ ] off why period I talked to
Rome she doesn't really listen like
Gaby's sort of just on her phone I
talked to my mom she's not even
listening Julian same thing I'm going
crazy I tell myself I'm just gonna go to
bed and do I meet and greet and get out
of it get out I hate this place I get up
in the morning super early and get ready
I go outside and have a brief talk with
one of the women employees who was in a
ditch if his patting dirt into some
bricks of some sort outside and making
like an outside bed I'm trying to make
nice with her telling her to open a
barbecue place instead of run this in or
something.idk and then on my way back
from this interaction I get lost inside
this in for so long there's a blue tarp
with rocks holding like a river of
revenues as revenue I think ravine of
rotting floor people and employees are
everywhere
his large rooms that look like oversized
dark bedrooms with 10 or more people
living in them I keep walking and
walking past rooms like these with
people living in them and I'm just
trying to get back to my room when I see
this attic door cracked open no way was
that the room that everyone talks about
I crack it open more there's a simple
wooden table with five men I did not
know and my dad I walk up the weird
steps and confront him how could he be a
part of this elite controlling group it
was him all along it was real I overhear
them say yeah but I just loved the idea
of her blowing up you know as I
interrupted them like they were
manipulating situation downstairs to get
our reactions through small televisions
that they were watching everything my
dad do this I was having all these
racing chicken-egg scenarios in my head
like did I actually just become
successful on YouTube because my dad
worked up in the top top high order and
manipulated it to be so or did he get
this position as a result considering
what was going on I had a feeling it was
the former because I just imagined him
pushing for his daughter like he liked
me a lot but as soon as I became an
object of jealousy he sabotage my life
as I said in my head like he always does
mind you know this is like I have no
idea I wasn't surprised but was somehow
and he and the others looked up from the
table somewhat surprised like they
didn't know I was coming but got very
quiet my dad just said I'm sorry and
then all of a sudden my brother steps
out from the side and says nothing he
has a sad look on his face and just
hands me my ID and a book and flips a
switch the attic door opens and I never
realized it had closed I was so angry
that I just found out all the stuff
downstairs had been manipulated all my
life essentially had been manipulated by
a group of men including my father and
brother I wasn't even really paying
attention I heard about this room and I
was going to spill the beans I looked
down the stairs and couldn't wait to
tell Rome everything she was gonna die
when she found out what YouTube had been
doing I looked down and the entire in
had changed not as
single person was in it it was like The
Shining everything was sparkling and
brand-new the door to the Attic was
completely sealed and gone I walked
through the end and there's a weird
there was weird elevator music playing
there was nothing no one it was sinking
it how real the rumor was why it was a
rumor and why you couldn't tell anyone
the truth because I had like shifted
realities I look at the book my brother
gave me which I don't remember exactly
what it was but I think it was a Holy
Bible with a small white piece of paper
with the old-timey black print the name
of a song on it I don't recall but mine
was something like yellow mustard on it
and of this of course was rumored to be
the song that played when you died I
died it hit me I died but it wasn't
hitting me because I was sort of just
floating out like I was on a moving
walkway of this gorgeous new Inn I saw
the outside was like glistening knew
everything was I had some thoughts as I
left like what happens now do I live
here now am I gonna haunt it what do I
do
what do I do here down I don't feel dead
at all and where am I going I did I see
a window and outside I see a bus I know
I'm getting on that bus I get outside
and I see this kid I knew and my friend
Rachel Park I look at them like oh wow
you guys died too this kid said yeah I
guess I was having a really big bathroom
orgy is frowned upon it fit god I forget
what Rachel said she did but they were
both along the lines of that VidCon and
youtuber we're now just offing people
that weren't cooperating all three all
three of us had the same attitude almost
like not very worried like we just lost
the video game or something and I
remember there being in a at least this
or at least that we get on the bus
because we just somehow know to get on
the bus it's around this time I see
Kermit and I get really excited and he
jumps up with me on the bus until I
realized that this means curving good we
take a long bus ride and out the window
on it we are watching these classic
YouTube videos of people that have all
disappeared and
zooming all the people that YouTube have
gotten rid of which is what started the
rumor in the first place everyone was
going away and never being heard from
again I start to recall a video called
how YouTube got rid of me and I escaped
or something like that and recalled the
first couple of minutes of him saying he
was in Italy or something it seemed like
trolling click baiting I didn't believe
it so I hadn't watched the whole thing
anticipating that I'm gonna get
somewhere and be able to watch it we get
off the bus and we are in Italy I for
some reason open this bag that I pick up
when we stop and all of my belongings
that are important are neatly organized
in it like my passport and everything
okay
I got with Rachel and other kid out the
front door finally on the street on some
grass we don't know where we're going
it's just like we got out of jail I was
still smoking cigarettes in this dream
so I light up one of the cigarettes in
my bag we were walking and talking about
what songs were that we died to we were
laughing like oh that's it so weird if I
had known I would wanted a better song
it seems as if we did not talk about how
or when we died nor did we actually know
I got to thinking about my last video I
posted and realized it was like
reviewing bad apps version of Pokemon go
that was my last video off worse we kept
talking and walking when all of a sudden
I looked down on my finger and my entire
fingertip had melted off and blood was
everywhere I said oh guys remember how
we said we were dead but don't really
feel that so I'm sure we aren't actually
dead look what I just did to my finger I
can't feel pain just as I say that we're
walking passing on their bus station
under construction one of the workers
sees Rachel and picks up her hatchet and
throws it directly at Rachel's head and
hits her square in the skull she's
laying on the ground trying to get this
guy off of her and is working to take
the axe out of her head like he just
wants to keep using it I'm sort of
freaking out like okay we really were
really really dead so we're like zombies
and Kermit is the zombie I'm a zombie
so you can die again holy [ __ ] I see
another axe in the ground as I run to
throw it at his head he falls back and
dies Rachel stands up with the axe in
her head and rips it out this is all I
remember from
except that this is why no one can talk
because people are now hunting us in
this reality like zombies I was
desperately trying to find a way to talk
to someone on the other side how can I
find a way people need to expose the the
green brothers and what they are doing
this is horrible this is the kind of the
end I think us in Italy somewhere
realizing that everyone that sees us is
hunting us we are dead we're never going
back that's at the end there was some
loose stuff here I just don't remember
now that's the whole thing Wow right
[ __ ] Wow right
what is that I've just sneeze [ __ ]
Wow the [ __ ] was that drink and how is
that that's like that's what dreams are
like like they make no sense
I was like writing it well while I'm
like half awake half asleep and I was
like I'm just gonna write down exactly
what happened in the dream as I
remembered it you must have been really
like half asleep because the only way
you can remember that many details is if
you're half asleep well yeah and that's
why it's like not written like in any
sort of way that anyone can understand
like you know when you're dreaming and
you already understand the context but
like this was the like always murmurs
about what happens to people that
disappear from online like they get
reset like even that's the first
sentence that I wrote but that was like
the whole context of the dream is like
you're living in alternate reality
YouTube land where like people are
disappearing from the internet but like
you can't convey it because that's just
the context of your dream yo that [ __ ]
was way crazier than a thousand T so
well I guess what was so crazy to me in
the dream because I do remember dreaming
it was that I had just you know everyone
was look so terrible to me and then I go
upstate I'd find the secret room and
like people are there to just sort of
like erase your existence like as a
person from the planet it's like the men
upstairs are
like our controlling all the pieces
they're like the god and everyone else
downstairs you think you know they are
but they really are just a piece of a
you know like a pawn manipulation
I just couldn't like I can't express the
feeling of being like realizing that
you're dead and being like I want to
tell someone on the other side what
happened but you can't [ __ ] that is so
crazy right I'm like I'm like getting
the the shivers are now hearing that
like that's that's crazy well I mean
it's not quite what I remember but I do
like even when I was like I don't
remember what it was I do remember
opening an attic door and being like
there's people up there I mean I've had
dreams where I'm like 80% sure I'm dead
and like I've in the dream proceeded
with what to do next
like like you said like you want to tell
someone or like if I'm dead like I want
to I want to see what this means or
where I am or who I have with me or how
did I die I remember dreams like that
but it's just that's so vivid and like
it brings me into dreamland hearing that
like that's what nice yeah that's like
everything about that dream is oh man
[ __ ] [ __ ] crazy and like I know
exactly you know I don't know exactly
but I think you know I think I know your
feeling when you have that dream right
like it makes no sense it's like
completely ridiculous and made up like
holy [ __ ] you kind of just blew my mind
why because I I did not think it was
going to be that I thought it was gonna
be a lot more jumbled and kind of
nonsensical that was like that was like
you know that was that was like it was I
can understand where that sort of
stemmed from in your brain yeah you know
what I mean and I think that's what's
crazy about it it just it feels profound
it doesn't feel like just a bunch of
nonsensical happenings which a lot of my
dreams feel like or at least I remember
them what was kind of nonsensical it was
like I woke up and was like what the
[ __ ] was that you know I mean it's not
like it made perfect sense no they made
a lot more sense into it it made a lot
more sense then I
I expected well I think if you really
try it like you know a lot of days when
you wake up you can't really remember
what you're dreaming about it wasn't
anything that was worth writing down but
like if you have one of those morning's
where you wake up and you remember your
dream if you just wake up and try to
write it down as fast as you can like I
challenged myself when I wrote that too
I was like I want to write down as much
detail as I can about everything because
I know it's not gonna make sense to me
when I read it back sometime if you you
purposely detailed everything more than
you needed to
but like if you try and do it like I'm
surprised I don't remember writing that
much like it's long I'm challenge you
that if you try to do it and then read
it back some other time yeah that I
think you'd be capable of writing more
than you think jr. I mean because a
dream journal is sort of like I've done
that before where it's like sentences or
like you know just the topic but if you
really challenge yourself to like write
down everything that you remember yeah I
think you'd be surprised how much you
can remember in that moment yeah you
know that was wild that was [ __ ] wild
I kind of I just had kind of little
speeches I feel like I have dreams like
that all the time where at the end of it
you have some sort of like realization
but I don't write them down I see I
don't I don't remember this dream I
wrote it down in in September and I'm
like I don't even know what's gonna
happen or I feel I mean it's obviously
way shorter this is still pretty long
now I want to hear yours your turn [ __ ]
all right
don't compare the two because it's
probably not nearly as crazy all right
I'm just gonna read word for word yeah
because I don't know what most this
means dream journals dream one September
September 3rd when did you write this
like were you still half sleeping no I I
wrote at 12:03 so I had unless I unless
I woke up at 12:03 because it might have
been a late night it's possible okay at
a condo type place that isn't mine I'm
sitting or something with Marlin the
house is nice and there's a bunch of
people there when we are leaving
try to flag down an uber because I
didn't have my car but he didn't know
where to pick us up so I got in his car
and he tries oh my god I just got a
flash of remembering my name holy [ __ ]
okay oh [ __ ] alright I try to flag down
a new verb but he he didn't know where
to pick us up so I got in his car and he
tries to drive me home alone without
Marlon I say please go back and get
Marlon he says okay whatever you want
but he was very shifty so I said I'd
like to take a different car Thanks next
scene we're out back at the backyard of
a small house how dreams work though
just like there's no closure it just
goes to the next the dream you know very
distinctly remember oh my god this is
like [ __ ] crazy
I very distinctly remember getting in
that car was like a town car and we were
going the wrong way on the freeway and I
was without Marlon and I was like yo I
need to get out of this car yeah and
then cut so we're in the backyard of a
small house sitting in the table I had
just seen some white belt get promoted
in the yard to Bluebell this is this by
September though I had my lube out so
this is then out of nowhere spawns a
miniature marbles like the size of an
iPhone five tiny and at the same time
spawns a miniature cat the cat was white
we didn't know where these things came
from or what to do with them so he tried
to take care of them but they began to
bite us one of the people I was with
dropped either marbles or the cat a
normal distance but they broke their arm
then marbles bit me and held on like a
snake and let go and the cat ate marbles
okay oh my god this is [ __ ] next scene
I'm trying to take Jenna to the snow
mountain to ski or something we were in
a Jeep fat chance we take a wrong turn
so we have to back out of a very
difficult tiny hill turns out my mom is
there and tries to talk
to us but I'm not having not now mom we
are then at dinner with my family my mom
being short with me and me to her Marlin
being especially annoying and backhanded
then Marlin follows Jenna and myself to
a restaurant I thought we were already
at dinner he start wheeling our dinner
date so I keep telling him to leave he
won't so I keep getting mad Marlin yeah
then this annoying dude is bothering our
table and I'm so mad at this point from
my mom acting like that and my brother
acting like that so I snap on the guy
and grapple him and choke him
unconscious Julianne as I returned to my
table people are thanking me a few
minutes later that guy wakes up and is
deliriously walking about the restaurant
trying to find his friends he finds them
ends up on a motorcycle and somehow gets
a rope from his bike caught on a giant
massive truck in the road we follow them
to park to the parking garage where
there is a shootout and Jenna and I
survived like what the [ __ ] was god I
think I shot one guy but the rest had
killed each other except for one guy
remained at the end he said shoot in the
air and pretend you're dead so I did and
lay there pretending I'd been shot while
he did - I think I woke up then hmm
Oh see that sounds like a dream like a
that's how dreams work you know what I
mean
[ __ ] [ __ ] that that's like a full
night's sleep that you just described
you know yeah they call you like that
mine was right in the morning when I
woke up so I remembered that because it
was so visually there yeah that sounds
like what you dreamt from like 3 a.m. to
like 7 a.m. like three hours of dreaming
like totally different [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
crazy
see the more dream well here's the thing
I I'm convinced like a lot of the times
I'm convinced when I'm half asleep
waking up and thinking about a dream I'm
convinced like this is stupid and sleep
sounds nicer right so
don't do it but if I really keep the
notebook my my bread my bed and really
do it I'm totally down to do these more
often because this is [ __ ] profound
like the reading the first bed of that
dream and then all of a sudden like
myself back into what it felt like
that's crazy isn't it there's nothing
like that sensation yeah I don't like
the last scene where hit the guy comes
up to me and he's like shooting there
and pretend like you got shot yeah I
remember that scene that's crazy [ __ ]
weird that's really crazy [ __ ] weird
no you grabbed are you happy I grabbed
you grappled someone unconscious at a
restaurant and then people thanked you
yeah and then he was just like drunk
poor that guy his rope got caught on a
truck on the highway he's got [ __ ]
they're dealing I love what you're just
casually driving down the freeway in the
wrong direction and then you're just in
a backyard yeah oh yeah totally
[ __ ] well I know I want to do more of
these now well like according to those
dream things like there's no way to
analyze our dreams really I mean you
know what that's what you guys do okay
my my dream I died in my dream I guess
but I didn't feel like I died it was
only a realization and then like there
is no like what you do and after you're
dead what does that mean what the [ __ ]
does that mean
but what's weird is like my dream had
nothing to do with guns or killing
people and then just somehow
automatically ends with gunfights like I
don't understand that I don't know I
don't know
well these are some of your dreams in
the comments leave us some of your
dreams but also if you if you feel like
you have any idea what our dreams mean
enlighten us and we will definitely do
more of these right yeah for sure it's
fun this is fun yeah this I kind of want
to go dream that oh if you if you want
better dreams take zma and house with
dreams oh my god be careful though be
careful the first night you take it
it'll be better after the first night
VMAs don't you describe with Z MA
is a supplement made up of zinc
magnesium and vitamin b6 yes so it's not
like a sleep aid there's a sound tonin
it's nothing like that Julian takes it
at night for repairing muscles and it's
like it's not it's not specifically for
repairing muscles there's nothing in it
yeah but there's nothing in it that
innately repairs muscles it's more of
replenishing and it's generally for men
but women can take it too it's generally
it replenishes what an active male loses
throughout the day of being an active
male so that they can sleep deeper sleep
better and get more rested in the
morning so if you take the ma and you
react well to it you'll wake up feeling
way more rested than you have that's
like the the stuff that's in it is not
anything different that would define
like a multivitamin for some reason but
like Knox it's the interaction between
specific it I was like good [ __ ]
night it knocks you I remember the first
few nights I read you to it knocks you
good makes you wake up feel nice and
rested but lately I found the s knack
brand which s knack is the company
created by the founder of zma his name
is Victor Conti created zma and the
company a snack their brand of zma is
something I've recently been in love
living it's vegan but I've been recently
in love with because it really [ __ ]
with your dreams and I like it it has an
effect like if I don't take it and then
I take it anyway thank you guys for
hanging out with us for another podcast
this was a really good one I feel weird
and investable nice and weird and
vulnerable right weird telling someone
you dreams yeah
little props to you I mean yours is way
long in the month it's [ __ ] me and
check out sponsors in the in the link
below in your pants thank you man
we appreciate you I will see you guys
next week on another podcast
hopefully by now the page rates of our
t1